[Music]
the excitement could not have been any
bigger when the bounty hunter boba fett
ascended jabba's thrown during the
credits of the final episode of the
mandalorian following the official
announcement of the book of boba fett
that was more than a year ago and
finally the time has come on december
29th the disney plus series will be
released on the streaming platform and
in the meantime we can already look
forward to all kinds of teasers and
trailers however they're still rather
reserved with regard to the plot of
course that leaves all the more room for
speculation after ascending the throne
we can assume that there will definitely
be a power struggle between the crime
syndicates and indeed we've already seen
a lot of that however since solo is a
star wars story and the final season of
clone wars it has become quiet around
the subject that is why we are going to
refresh your knowledge about the big
criminal syndicates in this video and
give you a little preview of the plot as
far as we can guess it
a total of five syndicates are widely
established in the galaxy we know
crimson dawn from solo a star wars story
meanwhile black sun and the pike
syndicate played a major role in clone
wars probably the most famous cartel is
the hot cartel to which job the hut also
belongs lastly there's the crymora
cartel which will be rather unknown to
most of you as it was primarily covered
in the star wars comics
so first let's take a closer look at the
crimson dawn syndicate the syndicate
joined the so-called shadow collective
at the time of the clone wars under the
leadership of dryden boss who was led by
maul formerly known as darth maul like
the other syndicates they first
retreated following oro 66 to observe
developments around the galactic empire
although vos remained as the head of the
organization maul continued to pull the
strings in the background the
headquarters of crimson dawn was the
starship first light from this flying
fortress they grew to become the most
feared syndicate during the empire in
part due to their brutality after the
death of dryden boss kira assumed
controller was ordered directly from
maul to davomir she continued to run the
organization even after the death of
doth city's former apprentice and sought
to overthrow the empire to create equal
opportunities for all factions in the
galaxy this made crimson dawn one of the
main targets of the empire making them
not as strong in the new republic
however the syndicate still helped
influence politics by repeatedly bribing
notable senators boba fett also still
has a score to settle with crimson dom
after all they stole han solo from him
was frozen in carbonite while he was on
his way to jabba the syndicate earns its
credits mainly by stealing and smuggling
rare minerals and drugs after the fall
of the empire they also collected all
sorts of rare sith artifacts and
holocrons
the black sun is considered crimson
dawn's closest ally and had the entire
planet of mustafar on its control under
the rise of the empire it had
established a vast espionage on
blackmail network which gave them
influence on all major governments
during the clone wars black sun
reluctantly joined the shadow collective
though the latter did not give them much
choice
the black sun maintained the largest
army of any syndicate training thousands
of warriors to defend mustafar in the
event of an invasion after the fall of
the republic they fled to smerf to
establish their new headquarters since
darth vader was building his castle on
mustafar nevertheless they continued to
flourish under the empire so after its
fall they kept trying to sabotage the
new republic shortly after the battle of
jakku they corrupted some senators into
voting against sending troops to the
desert planet most of the imperial
forces had to retreat to it their plan
failed however as han solo managed to
persuade the senators the black sun was
known primarily for its shameless slave
trade however in addition to living
beings they also traded weapons and
information which is why they had a
great interest in the continuation of
the galactic civil war
the pike syndicate is probably one of
the most well-known syndicates among
fans thanks to the clone wars series
they were one of the main opponents of
crimson dawn but they were also
compelled to join the shadow collective
just like black sun the pike species
lived on the planet obadiah and made
their money mainly by trading spies
after the death of jabba they had a
large crate monopoly spice was the most
common rock in the galaxy and was bad in
both the old republic and the empire as
well as the new republic most spies was
exploited in the minds of castle besides
that the bike syndicate also dealt with
coaxium the fuel for hyper space
technology in order to get this spikes
from the asteroid planet castle to
ovidaya the pike smug of the dragon
cargo ships and similar spacecraft that
made the famous castle run only one
pilot ever made the flight in just under
12 parsecs we assume you know we're
talking about however after the fall of
the empire the pike syndicate lost its
power steadily mainly due to the
reintroduction of the sector rangers who
provided law and order in the different
regions of the known galaxy
the crimora syndicate had its prime
especially during the time of the
galactic empire one of the main reasons
for this was they provided the empire
with information about secret rebel
bases and lost jedi after the
destruction of the first death star the
syndicate was supposed to supply the
empire with new essential raw materials
and weapons to speed up the construction
of the second death star however the
talks failed so vader negotiated
directly with jabba and the crimeora
were henceforth considered enemies of
the empire together with the droid gotra
they raided supply routes of the empire
from then on the droid codrtra was a
group of battledroids from the clone
wars that had not been deactivated they
also represented an underground group
that attempted to sabotage the empire
and fought for the emancipation of the
droids however in the war against the
underworld the syndicate was almost
completely destroyed by major general
casualty only after the fall of the
empire was the syndicate able to regain
importance
the hutt clan is the oldest and biggest
organization of the five syndicates they
have been operating since before the
high republic and established their
reputation mainly in contraband and
spice trade their home planet was
nilhuta which resembles a huge swamp
during the clone wars they managed to
expand their sphere of influence due to
the republic's involvement in the fight
with the separatists throughout the
galaxy however they allowed republic
forces to use their hyperspace routes
indeed they were the syndicate that
resisted the shadow collective the
longest and strongest it wasn't until
the capture of jabba's palace that they
joined mullen attacking the mandalorian
capital during the empire jabba was the
head of the hot family and council while
the other members ruled only small
sectors of the clan yet before his death
darth vader wiped out the entire council
making jabba the sole ruler of all hot
territories jabba has left a huge power
vacuum after his death it was impossible
to fill thanks to this vacuum the zone 2
pride crime syndicate which had
previously been crushed by the empire
was able to rise again it was considered
the greatest adversary to the hot cartel
what influenced the ascent of jabba
throne by boba will have on the clan we
will surely find out very soon
of course no one knows exactly what will
happen next however the plot can be
guessed a little by assuming jabba's
throne boba has certainly drawn some
attention to himself until now it seems
more like a rumor that one of the
greatest bounty hunters of all time was
able to free himself from the maw of the
sarlacc his goal is clear to rule
instead of taking orders this will
certainly not please everyone as we have
already seen in the trailers boba has
summoned several organizations to his
table consisting of trandocians
clauduinians and equalish
so far no syndicate is known that is
explicitly composed of these species
merely the rope of the clitorinians is
reminiscent of that of the black sun
along with them he's trying to create a
new organization in the world besides
the already established syndicates
others will no doubt also try to obtain
java's power after bip fortuna the more
so because it's not yet fully clarified
whether fortuna only had control over
the palace or also other parts of
jabba's business this appears to be the
case as we could see city in the trailer
in which an athorian is in power in the
dialogues we hear between fanuc shan and
him he wants to be a better ruler and
stop just using brute force to unite the
people under him whether that works in a
world of criminals where one rams a
knife into the other's back at any given
opportunity is yet to be seen shan seems
to be the devil over his shoulder always
wanting to show him the more brutal way
out what we all hope to see is of course
a few more flashbacks that show the way
he escaped from the sarlacc and what has
happened since then here you go those
are all the big syndicates and we hope
you enjoyed a little preview of the book
of boba fett which syndicate would you
want to see in the series or do you
think they won't play a part at all did
we even possibly forget one let us know
in the comments see you next time
[Music]
you